so dr peter uni uh the head of the
science table uh said this morning that
the science table was not consulted
about the decision to end the mass
mandate on march 21st and he also said
that uh this decision isn't about
science he says there was political
pressure so what do you say to the fact
that
uh the the science table which you've
been consulting all along
wasn't consulted about this decision and
says it's not about science well let me
be very clear there's no pressure on dr
moore i follow
the advice and the recommendations of
the chief medical officer of ontario he
consults with a
science table and we're looking forward
to the recommendations that he's putting
forward at 11 o'clock today
and we're going to take his advice
on the time frame moving forward with
the mass and you know like it look
around the world no matter if it's uh
cdc down in the us and the rest of the
world
you know we've been super cautious
matter of fact i've been probably
accused of being the most cautious
leader in north america
when it comes to this pandemic but i i
want to be cautious and we're going to
take those recommendations and and move
forward with the advice of dr moore
which has done an incredible job for the
people of ontario
okay uh if assuming you're going to
accept his recommendations for listing
lifting the mass mandate
what happens if uh if things change in
the spring like if if there is another
wave how confident are you that there's
not going to be another wave of of covet
in the coming weeks thanks for that
question mike no one has a crystal ball
when it comes to this pandemic
but we feel we've been invested strongly
in our health care system into the
people right right around this room here
been absolute champions and we're very
very grateful we've all uh not only
ontario but the whole world has learned
so much over the last two years and
we're in much better shape than than we
were prior to this pandemic and i'll
give give one one example
um you know right at the beginning of
the pandemic everyone was running around
looking for ppe and
and you know trying trying to get it
from overseas and i remember saying
we'll never be in that position again
and we never will we have 3m that stood
up a facility that are producing
millions and millions of n95 mass we
have
local companies making gowns and face
shields
and surgical mass too
so we're well equipped on on that and we
stood that up or i should say the people
of ontario stood it up because that's
who did it um in a matter of a couple
months
so right now we're we're doing fairly
well but we're always going to be
cautious and anyone who wants to wear a
mask mike
they're more than welcome to
um it's going to be up to the the people
morning premiere jason got older with
chc hey
um
is it acceptable for municipalities or
even public health units to continue
with their mass mandates if that's the
direction that they choose to go to well
they're going to have to go through uh
dr moore the chief medical officer
and he again he's done an incredible
incredible job but i just want to thank
all the public health officers
throughout the two years have really
worked hard along with
our frontline
healthcare folks they've done an
incredible job we wouldn't be here today
if people of ontario didn't follow the
protocols that were laid out by local
public health officers and the chief
medical officer
and and the great health care folks here
we know how covered 19 measures have
been pretty divisive um aren't you
concerned for
a lack of civility or even some cases
abuse for people who choose to keep them
on
no you know something we're going to
move forward cautiously and if someone
wants to keep them on
god bless them you know good good for
them but i know a lot of people don't
want to keep them on and
again we aren't leading the way in this
we're kind of middle of the pack i know
down down in the u.s with cdc their
recommendations
about getting rid of the mass but it's
going to be up to the the people of
ontario if you want to keep your mask on
keep it on
if you want to take it off take it off
but we have to move move forward from
this like people
people are exhausted
you know and the poor kids in those
classrooms too like we we got to move on
yes
hey jamie hi mr premier good morning um
what's going to happen march 21st so the
mass going to come off in a lot of
places are restrictions to uh outdoor
facilities and indoor facilities going
to be lifted
well you know i'm not going to steal dr
moore's thunder i'm gonna
probably get 30 minutes yeah i'm going
to let him
give you the details
he has a very strong plan
and
he's worked really hard on it as well
with
with collaboration with our great
minister of health
and uh we feel it's a strong plan so
jamie with all due respect i got to kind
of let dr moore roll out the details of
that if if that's fine
and
it is a huge decision or a huge
announcement why won't you make the
announcement it's only 30 minutes away
plus also
yeah why won't you make the announcement
it's a huge announcement all of ontario
is waiting for the shoe to drop why
aren't you making the announcement well
i'm i would hear making a fabulous
announcement i'm i'm out in the media
almost every day every second day
and i i really believe uh this is an
opportunity for dr moore to put his
recommendations out i'll be commenting
after but you know doctor
dr morris works so hard day in and day
out
and i i
i don't know i just don't feel i should
be out there trying to steal his thunder
this this is an incredible person that's
worked so hard so let's
let dr moore put his his plan out there
and recommendations
and uh we'll move forward all right
thanks everyone so i just want to thank
everyone once again thank you so much
for everything that you do
i'm just so so grateful and uh we're
gonna we're gonna get a beautiful
uh new uh we're gonna revitalize this
this whole uh building and
and thank you for your leadership and
well you're an absolute champion this
would not be happening without you and
the great leadership of of minister
elliot so thank you
you